the social media platforms have made it
very clear how they feel about this guy
right
all right never mind never mind logan
never mind what's this clown talking
about how was he how are they losing
money
so we already watched andrew tate's
response to logan paul going in on him
you and you know his pretty eyes it's
what you took out of that conversation
apparently it took a little more than
that yeah all right this is this was
like his big message to andrew tate
after he got banned where he cowers to
the matrix oh i only saw it you only saw
kate's reaction exactly so we're gonna
react to the entire thing where he talks
about tape how long is this don't worry
about it all right andrew tate got
banned from the internet from everybody
andrew tate banned from this social
media platform and then the domino
effect now he's how do we feel about
like that's where that's going to go if
you just give him that's where he's
leading he's got he's trailing us right
into it i'm getting there
i'm getting there brother i'm holding
your hand through this mountain i
appreciate it all right so so uh you
know
i guess i guess in a way although i was
disappointed i couldn't post this video
which which i again believe would have
gotten a lot of traction
life really worked out because
now you're in a situation where
and we're going to dive into andrew tate
i don't feel like platforming this guy
i don't
feel like giving him the blessing of
being my dance partner in the ring
especially after
the social media platforms have made it
very clear how they feel about this guy
right oh the social media platforms made
it clear how they feel about them ah
all right never mind never mind logan
never mind we're not worthy no you're
right you're okay he's totally right
what were we thinking they why didn't we
just listen to the fact checkers let's
just let's just turn off the computer
and get out of here yeah we've learned
everything we need to know social media
says take an ad listen i'm not saying
say it's the same i don't know
everything i know but i have watched a
lot of tate in the past month and a half
as you all know and i have yet to see
something bandworthy i haven't seen a
single bandworthy thing i would even um
put a little call out here to like
fellow creators and even jj like
you want to re-platform this guy we
don't dog why are we re-platforming this
[ __ ] why is he really this relevant i
mean i know i live under a mom rock but
what's happening here why does he matter
an agent in the matrix that's popular i
don't know how to explain it to you okay
look jake paul his own brother tweeted
that he supports andrew um and free
speech he thinks he should have a
platform so how do you disagree that
that much with your own brother though
that you're calling out other platf
you're calling other creators saying how
how could you guys even want to give
this guy a platform meanwhile your
brother does isn't that just kind of
like how could anyone want to it's like
dude your best friend essentially your
blood are they best friends him and his
brother yeah i mean well they're allowed
to have different opinions
on your shows you want to you want to
give him another opportunity to speak
and and spread his agenda because um
whether you
believe it or not the [ __ ] that andrew
tate is saying will have a ripple effect
much more dangerous than you can imagine
because his narrative is truly hateful
his rhetoric has extreme negative energy
in it and it will affect impressionable
young people in a way that will not show
until i personally have done more
push-ups this week than i have all year
because of watching these date videos so
you're going to tell me that that's a
negative effect on my life he's
essentially you know lady push-ups the
tate's mentioned this in their video
it's in it it's it kind of comes back to
this where he's like the impressionable
youth will take this and and and be
dangerous with it like what are they
going to be dangerous with what like how
are they going to become dangerous he
promotes protecting women like yeah he's
made jokes or it's like don't give cpr
to if i'm don't i'm not gay i don't give
cpr but it's like he's making it seem
like you're too stupid to see that
that's bs there is nothing there are so
few things more more dangerous than
limiting free speech and or eliminating
free speech and i'd sound like a broken
record even to myself i know that is a
danger and this guy actually advocating
for that the fact that there were little
drones out there going yes yes free
speech bad tate bad is really scary to
me it is it's crazy because they have
voting power and they will continue to
recruit little little little numb skulls
i just wanna try i wanna know what about
his message is dangerous to the youth so
like if i had to think of something i'd
say the way he talks about women maybe
like how you should you should be a be a
leader to them and then some dudes might
take that in a weird sense and get too
dominant over women that's the only
thing i could really think of but that's
not even what people say also talk about
that that's how people interpret it also
do you say you know to be respectful to
women and kind and and treat them well
when they're in your presence you know
no exactly make sure that they're cared
for they have everything they want they
need you open the door you treat them
like a lady i'm just i'm just trying to
think of what this danger is the danger
what is dangerous that these men will
think for themselves station of
censorship right because people's
slippery slope freedom is speech you
want to say what you want to say
don't even say the platforms thing but
you can't do that when your platform
that you want to spread your word on is
privately oh my god money is a factor
i already went into why that's such a
terrible take i i still i heard your
your opinion like yeah it is private but
i think that is such a horrible take
because if there was only half of my
opinion their rules are that if you
follow the guidelines and you don't
break them then you can have a platform
so if he doesn't break the rules and
then they can still ban him where does
it end but i also said that you and i
have not read those terms and conditions
because it's like it'd be quicker to
read the bible and they're so deep that
i guarantee that somewhere in there
there's like here's all our rules and oh
here's an extra rule all those rules
kind of matter but if we just decide we
want to get rid of you we're getting rid
of you all right whatever it's [ __ ]
and it doesn't make it right does that
matter well the lawsuit that matters
because it gives people no it gives
people no recourse when they when they
agree to that contract if they say we
can just do it for any freaking reason
so this guy again hasn't given a single
real solid reason why tate is dangerous
and he's going back to this this private
company thing andrew tay is spreading
his speech on
have a bottom line to hit
their sole objective is to make money
now if you have a bad actor there's not
friends that's costing them money what
the [ __ ] are you talking about what's
this [ __ ] clown talking about how is
he how are they losing money their sole
objective isn't just money too it's
control
don't be a good
okay so maybe some of their advertisers
are trying to get rid of them
some of them have their own some of them
are disgusting right so like say he has
four good takes and you're like oh i
could i see how that makes sense
one then is [ __ ] up right so when
andrew came to the people watching his
content in a entertaining way in a way
that he could lead you from thought a to
thought b in a cohesive way
when he becomes your your
your idol your god the person you look
up to as a creator online because you
shouldn't have like a god that you look
up to like you can look up to him and
like take what he says like to your own
interpretation and be like yeah you know
he's right i should work harder i should
hit the gym isn't that his whole point
it's that's exactly this guy this guy is
also assuming that every one of andrew
tates is stupid enough yeah it's just
stupid enough to believe literally
everything he says with that like you
can't differentiate a joke in something
literal you can't interpret something
into how it would come into effect in
your own life he thinks that these
people are [ __ ] droids
that's what kids are doing nowadays
right you're at home sure you have your
parents sure you have your friends but
who do you admire online who are you
watching who's influencing you
influencers because my son doesn't hear
you let's look up to logan paul i think
what what do you want us to do bro you
want to look up to you i mean he's a
successful actress
he's got a business like if you put it
on paper and you don't listen to any of
this [ __ ] right he's a he's a famous
youtuber he's a successful athlete
you're talking about logan paul man not
this clown okay this clown he's got
pretty eyes so there's a lot on paper
check check check that somebody could
look up to and this is the whole point
of cut through those layers and get in
there because listen to this this guy is
advocating for censorship like adolf
[ __ ] hitler did i've been fine with
with logan paul lately too and i
followed his content i've liked it i
just this this just and it's like what
are you why are you going back to
censorship man what are you doing i am
most again disappointed that he did not
learn any compassion from his own
experience of being censored made a
mistake as a kid got in trouble clearly
was forgiven and he didn't learn from
that and again tate didn't even really
make a mistake tate is just messing with
the matrix when the one take comes out
that says something women are your
property if your friend has a heart
attack you're not going to give him cpr
because that's gay if it's a dude like
there's there's a million different
[ __ ] like that's a joke you have no
sense of humor whatsoever i'm so glad
we're not friends with these people we'd
have no problem you actually look into
his women or my property take it it goes
deeper than women on my property like my
woman's like my car you have to like
actually watch it with context and it
makes more sense like yeah i look after
this woman it's the same reason that um
like men men just protect women like
it's your job as the man in a
relationship to protect your woman
right it's like when you were little
when daddy wasn't around you know he's
he you know he traveled for work you
belonged to me okay and then i was
protecting you in his like and then when
he was around he was protecting both of
us you belonged you you owned it and you
are still wearing it another thing is
that he said when he was saying about
the only fans thing how his girl if she
does only fans he takes 100 of the money
it's his girlfriend they're in a
relationship so in a relationship when
she makes the money that he's helping to
make she just gives it to the person
that's going to be more responsible with
the money and it's not like he's like
hoarding at all and he's like yeah [ __ ]
thank you it's like you're in a
relationship where you give to each
other you're loving it
i still don't agree with that you you
could watch that video if you want my
full take on it no need to repeat but
that's not dangerous regardless that i
don't agree with it or that you and i
disagree on it it's not [ __ ]
dangerous rhetoric give me a break he's
not like when the [ __ ] talks too much
much you know choke her out or when she
burns dinner give her a slap and then
give me a break
i'm sure there's plenty of people in the
matrix with regular
regular jobs both people have regular
jobs where they just put their money
together and the person that's more
responsible with the money takes care of
it well in an ideal situation there is
one person that's responsible and
that's that's how it goes yeah my thing
is but maybe in his case that's that's
what's happening mom always cuts off
sunny fast no my tape my point is that
they just they say something like that
he says woman on my property and it's
just it's not the full story and that's
they make it sound different than what
he really said and that's my only thing
i'm not even trying to fully defend him
like defend it and be like yeah woman
our property i'm not even trying to do
that i'm just trying to explain the
context but we know that they take
things out of context but really again
still not dangerous still not dangerous
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
dangerous this guy gets punched in the
face for a living and he calls a little
bit of little conversation that he
disagrees with dangerous yeah i don't
know let's keep going they're mixed in
they're mixed in with some takes that
are motivational that are inspirational
that do have some merit to them
we talked about this on the show with
jake the issue becomes
the the sentiment and how the person is
received is dependent on the audience
member and his audience is a very young
impressionable
unexperienced or inexperienced crowd of
of young men who by the way
fit into a current
uh visceral uprising that exists in this
world to to overthrow some long-standing
movements uh
towards the further validation and and
credibility of women and and other that
was like a kamala harris word salad blah
blah blah blah you didn't say anything
you just said a lot of words and didn't
say a thing who was this guy according
to t logan paul's boyfriend always have
to remember at the end of the day again
these these the platforms that banned
him can do whatever the [ __ ] they want
talk about your freedom
that's what he's calling out okay now
they're calling on what he's right
because
freedom of speech go for it brother you
can say whatever you want go in the
courtyard of the mall scream stand on a
[ __ ] table and say whatever you want
but when you are now at the mercy of
you know um an organization that has
brought you the visibility that you so
desperately seek
and now you want to not play by the
rules like this
that's okay though the question there
the question that that the
anti-censorship side is asking is at
what point does a legislative or
government body step in to regulate what
a private org that acts as the
mouthpiece of the public can do in these
situations every government
international federal state local little
town little schools every school
everybody has their own social media
channel and uses it to communicate with
the general public it is a very
important communication tool similar to
radio and television and you know
government is going to have to step in
and say you have to play by our rules
except the government as we've seen is
so corrupt that they like it better this
way they don't want it played by the law
they want it where they can go in the
back door and control things because
right now there is no legislative body
that can say twitter can ban this person
instagram can ban this person
censorship is a slippery slope yes i
agree with that does there need to be a
governing body to decide no there
doesn't bro the [ __ ] but otherwise
and by the way you know honestly i'd
kind of agree with that to an extent
that we don't need laws to come in
because i don't like the government
getting more involved and [ __ ] i just
think that it's the job of another
social media platform to take their
space so let twitter keep [ __ ]
censoring people [ __ ] twitter [ __ ] all
those when you have something like
amazon web services that owns
these major servers that can shut down
any website on earth at any time like
they did with parlor then then there do
we go and regulate that and say
everybody's got to be able to say what
they want no you're right we made a lot
of jokes when this stuff was first
coming up and and you guys made the
jokes about me shaving my head blah blah
so on and so forth and it led to
you know him following me probably and
saying this guy is going to be an ally
which he now knows that i'm not okay and
has called me out multiple times and
called me logan paul's boyfriend well
you are my brother yeah as i'm yours
brother your relationship uh my thoughts
are this
i i don't like the censorship i've said
this before but after the dana white um
conversation this is the last time we
brought up censorship i thought about it
because i watched what i said back and i
was like do i agree with what i said and
i had like this learning moment it's
like
i don't agree with what i said i'm
taking back my first thing i said on the
podcast i think the platforms have every
right to do what they want it's kind of
like if you're using their vehicle you
got to respect them you know i mean
you've got to respect their rules and
regulations it's their vehicle like you
said he didn't break the rules it's
their platform they put you at this but
if you kind of go in a direction they're
like hey man i don't want you using my
platform to take it in this direction
pin that that's my thought for that if
they have over how do if they have power
over all of it rules don't matter so you
basically just can't say one form like
one even form of thought you can't even
speak like on the right without getting
censored well but it brings up a curious
question so say all the super most of
the super or even medium
middle and right journalists they all
have youtube twitter accounts they
haven't been censored they haven't been
banned they're saying a lot of loud [ __ ]
why so why take because there's money
because to go back to logan's point of
earlier he is right there is some money
half the country pays attention to that
[ __ ] and they know that if they shut off
all conservative content that they would
lose
so much revenue
so it confuses me then or i haven't
figured it out yet okay so you're
keeping a lot of it why t is tate that
powerful and pervasive into the minds of
young people where he can get in there
and go and and really undo i know some
of this matrix type thinking it's a
crazy thought needs to go if that's the
case i've never watched any of his [ __ ]
to make an assumption like that oh oh
but
that's my favorite part he needs to go
i've never watched any of his [ __ ] where
where's the line for censorship where do
you draw your line in the sand if you're
going to talk about censorship and
drawing the line then you would have
been canceled eight years ago or
whatever it was when you're making
pictures of people in the [ __ ] line
there was no line he would have been
canceled right when he was showing a a
child someone's child even if it was an
adult that's someone's child hanging is
it when someone's rhetoric is racism to
death are you allowed to be sexist and
racist online because you know what kind
of agenda that perpetuates or should we
nip it in the butt before some bad [ __ ]
happens that's what i'm saying like what
i mean what does it take what does it
take no the government does not get to
decide what we can say and yeah you know
what anybody's allowed to be a racist
you're allowed you cannot get convicted
for the thoughts in your head you can't
if you act on that and you break any of
the laws like i'm not hiring you because
you're a white male and white males are
awful that's discrimination i'm not
hiring you because you're a black female
that's discrimination but for me to sit
and think in my head that i you know or
somebody to sit and think those you know
some hillbilly down in the south those
those sickos that killed armada what was
his name armand aubry i forget his first
name
yeah that poor kid i mean that was
terrible bunch of racists if they had
just sat and said something to each
other about it nothing would have been
fine but they went out and they killed
the kid yeah now you're going to jail
they're all in jail forever you know
what's funny is that there would be like
a dozen okay they deserve their there
will be a dozen kkk people in like the
middle of nowhere mississippi going out
getting together doing their thing and
the liberals will make it like the end
of the [ __ ] world and every black
person is gonna die and we need to kill
all conservatives and white men and then
the liberals will go and riot and burn
down cities in the name of justice
yeah i mean the kkk has a really [ __ ]
up history but of doing bad things no i
know you're not i just want to make that
clear today's kkk they're just [ __ ]
sitting there in the dark like a bunch
of weirdos oh yeah we're awesome like
all right [ __ ] nut cases go do your
thing but you're right but burning down
cities like we don't even talk about
that that happened that we talk about
[ __ ] not forgetting that i'm never
forgetting that [ __ ] that that person
probably shouldn't be given a voice
right because because
when you have again listen to this a
sucking chocolate entertaining orator
that kind of makes sense sometimes
and has a shitload of visibility i don't
like his eyes anymore or anything i hate
him i want to punch him i'm going to
kick him in the face if i punched him
i'd break my hand but i can kick the
[ __ ]
kid out of him
it looks like he's on like like matrix
pills like you look in his eyes and
there's a fog that the agents have
gotten to him i disagree but now
actually they're still pretty pretty
guys in history where charismatic
leaders with negative dangerous uh uh
agendas and platforms and visibility get
given an opportunity to spread their
word and then bad [ __ ] happens so
where's your line in this in the sand do
we want to let keep andrew tate keep
doing this before his subscribers of
little [ __ ] tick tock school boys
start doing negative bad [ __ ] to women
it's inspiring they already are it's
already spawning about okay they already
are let's hear let's hear this come on
what are they doing what have you got
his his rhetoric is already starting to
spawn on a full on next week i'm
interested in little baby
uh uh uh [ __ ]
andrew tate children was that you your
little baby can entertain children i
guess so and they're mothers the only
thing i've learned is to just treat a
woman with women with utmost respect and
protect them you're so good and kind and
thoughtful it's just frustrating when
people like i don't know dude it's they
just don't see the truth you can see
them they're starting to rise up and
here's one example they're not as well
spoken they're not as as uh they don't
have a few good takes they're they're
they're on the internet talking terrible
about women
i do want to see i do want to see an
example of this i always like to keep an
open mind if this is true let's see it
uh about a lot of things that he
probably understands at his 30
what 6 37 year old age point that these
people just don't get
and and they're and they're
but they do understand that that they
should get a sex change they think they
can't comprehend watching someone so we
have to censor him but these
five-year-old kids they can they can
take hormones and decide that they're in
different generations they're the same
clowns
is a g for wearing a you know a fluffy
dress that's normal okay let's go
the audience and they're starting to
build audiences of their own and so
you're already starting to see the
ripple effect of it yeah yes
and that's what these clowns either
can't see refuse to see or see but
continue to lie about i don't know which
it is you know how this ends we've seen
it
it's just weird too because it fits into
it it fits into an ongoing
wave of this type of activity i'm
telling you i've been saying it on the
show for a long time now
tick tock is
is
vicious is a vicious community of this
type of activity you go in the audience
you got a a guy and a girl arguing and
the girl and the people in the audience
all dudes i believe in equal rights and
lefts
my tick tocks equal rights for women and
equal lefts too you know what i'm saying
like they're the jokes about violence
towards women
uh about you know what is she talking
about show me one example i'm not i'm
not gonna what did he say equal left
violence against women
who's promoting violence against women
maybe it's out there you don't get puppy
dog i get nothing my puppy dog videos
because that's what i'm like
that's what i like you get boobs and
butts i don't get those
so maybe people who are interested in
violence against women just get fed up
violence against women
i don't know if that is a funny take
mikey i haven't even what's your problem
mikey here's the other thing that i want
to speak on because
i
have a
extremely keen
and unrelatable understanding of what
it's like to be canceled
by the entire world why
huh
it is interesting for me to watch
someone like andrew tate
be where he was and then get shunned and
blacklisted by the platforms that he
needs most
as much as he talks about being outside
of the matrix
now you're outside the club and we hear
you complaining that you can't get in he
didn't complain once not for a second
just for the record he didn't even know
him he said [ __ ] these platforms and go
in a rumble yeah it's long video
not not available on any of the
platforms obviously
it was his website absolutely yeah i
tried to watch it dude but it was like
when somebody starts out with like okay
it all started when i was three
that's enough that's another thing
i didn't want to so so so they have very
obviously not said the r word rumble he
said it was only available on his
website they don't want rumble and i
that's another now let's wait and see if
they say it and i may be proven wrong
but for now they're not saying it and it
just proves tate's point that he's got
you know youtube in his ears saying
here's what you can say here's what you
can't say and here's what we want you to
have a whole episode about right i
watched this guy who's actually probably
[ __ ] evil
try to make an accountability video and
again as someone who's been through it
and can safely say i came out on the
other side
understanding and pathetic
the man doesn't understand
he does not get it
he is also not a good person
we know the type of [ __ ] he says off
camera right as much as he says all
right maybe this is a joke i don't treat
it character character
no it's not here's what i'll say
he has built a platform on this return
to alpha masculine traditionalist
beliefs
where
uh you know woman at center of household
uh cooking for the kids cleaning raising
the kids man at war whatever not even
like fully what he says either it's not
fully what he says yeah of course
they're oversimplifying it once again
he's saying that like if i'm the one
paying all the bills taking care of you
and like like yeah like your job is to
[ __ ] cook and clean up the house my
job is to do everything else you can do
something you can have a role in this
relationship he just didn't really say
that he's like i can afford to have
people clean the house you don't even
have to clean the house just you know
here's the facts though just women since
the rise of feminism look at today's
young women they're [ __ ] miserable
they're miserable they screaming that
all they do is complain and talk about
their lives and they can't pay their
bills and this and that and they're
unfulfilled and they can't find love how
is this better how is this better yes
you should be able to choose if you want
a career or if you want to be a
homemaker but what they did is they
demonized being a mother and being a
homemaker and raising children and
supporting your husband and being part
of being a strong part of the team they
demonized that so that became not an
option because that's bad and that's low
that's beneath me and so now these women
the only choice became to be in a career
and they're miserable in their careers
crazy they hate it all so how so this
guy is making it seem like andrew tate
is saying something that's so bad it
wasn't so bad it wasn't so bad oh
sitting home took me an hour to clean
the house today dropped the kids off at
school going to pick the kids up you
know for some reason women that's
unfulfilling but it was fulfilling for a
lot of women and it still is to this day
and these people forget that and they
don't acknowledge the women that are
happy doing that and you know what
somebody needs to say it that it's okay
to do that
the situation the issue is with all of
that is
he is not a a traditionalist in his own
life he has no family he has no wife
he's 37 years old 36.
he has made the majority of his money
off of cam girls
only fans management pyramids and
casinos okay the the the downfalls
of the traditionalist mail and so my
question is
truly it's a good point i'll give it
i'll give you one for mike how can you
preach a return to traditionalism and
conservatism when your entire platform
and your entire net worth is based on
the same things that you preach again
there is an incongruence in those two
things but he is not truly preaching
you know to kind of cut through this
he's not preaching totally uh
traditional values he's not for him he
is flat out saying i've got a bunch of
women and they're all mine and i can go
out and have exercise as he calls it
with another woman and come back so he's
not sitting here trying to be ward
cleaver ward cleaver was like this 1950s
tv show character who is absolutely
perfect
and he's not trying to be word cleaver
or saying that he is so this guy the
incongruence is there but not it's not
that incongruent if you really think
about it because he's also not even
preaching to go out and do only fans
management and do all these things which
could ultimately hurt women because
these guys aren't like that would be
more that would make more sense if he
was preaching that then i would say like
okay yeah these guys probably don't know
how to properly treat a woman like you
do they might get crazy and that that's
where [ __ ] might go down is if you're
preaching for guys to go and do these
shady or business models right which it
totally has happened that way you know
in offline you know with pimps who treat
women really terribly so are the women
that do that that do those jobs evil too
i don't know whatever and he has given
me he's called me a hypocrite here's the
thing i am not i've said in my book i've
said on this show a million times i am
not your role model take the good pieces
take the hope take the courage take the
the drive to continue going against all
odds the way he's delivered his messages
have been dangerous since day one he
needs he needs a a torque and a full
overhaul on the way he delivers his
message do you know how that starts
he needs to change personally which
if everything he said about what he
believes is true
he's not gonna do
so as of now
my statement stands
that i made in your vlog
by 2023 he will not have a sliver of
relevancy hopefully hopefully
oh he throws in the hopefully because
he's not even sure of what he's saying
because he knows he's wrong he knows
he's wrong he's dead [ __ ] wrong [ __ ]
him i'm glad he's gone
wow you're a piece of [ __ ]
you are a piece of [ __ ] you know who i
don't like let's see there's a long list
do i want them to be erased nope they
should have their voice and there are
millions of men and women just in
america i can speak for who will fight
to the death for people they don't like
to have their
right to speak and this weakling is just
so willing to get on this high horse and
go yep i'm glad he's gone i hate the way
he says it too it's in such a snarky way
snug smug
would have worked a little smarter he
wouldn't have to be complaining outside
of the matrix about how there is a
matrix because what he's describing is
is just a freemason right yeah you want
to play by society's rules you don't
want to live in a country that protects
you you don't want health care i mean
he has money but he the the things he's
describing are an unrealistic freemason
type of life where you get water from
the well in your backyard and you don't
pay the you're almost like
like cool bro that's [ __ ] cool as you
sit inside your jet and trick everyone
who's subscribing to your [ __ ] [ __ ] i
absolutely am starting to believe even
more
they're watching this that tate is right
about this guy just having youtube in
his ear and i'm honestly starting to
believe it too completely a puppet it's
unbelievable it's really strange to
think is this man born and raised in
america this dude loves where is he from
he'll suck the nipple of the matrix no
no don't say things like that to me
so where is he where's he from tell me
where ohio okay so this is like all
american middle america boy
that's his number one ability
support censorship questionable dumb
vulnerable men
that's his point for sure
to just trick men that's it that's all
he's doing watching so nice you know
what i've seen um on our on our comments
some things that are like since i
started watching tate i lost 70 pounds
uh since i started watching tate i've
stopped smoking pot and you know i'm
doing really much better
you know in my work and my relationships
like i'm seeing things in our comments
that are positive i can only imagine
what he's getting i'm even getting this
guy's acting like yeah you're getting
positive messages give logan paul a new
reading one to ten i'm really
disappointed in him i don't even know
i'm kind of grossed out by him it's like
it's like crazy it's like like he be gv
grossed out too
make sure to follow us on rumble and all
of our social media platforms instagram
twitter tick tock instagram uh youtube
has been taking down some of our videos
so if you want to stay in touch with us
make sure to stay make sure to follow
some of those other places come on
oh can i talk i can just have my
instagram for one second we have a
minute
so no okay i'll do it later okay bye
all right i'll smell you later come back
for
[Music]
rather writing that the wall won't last
long